so we talked about republican senator
mitch
mcconnell ending the overt farce
that the last five weeks have been and
congratulating joe biden as
president-elect since after all
joe biden did win the election now we
immediately have the blowback to this
story
which is that almost instantly donald
trump himself
and trumpists including q anon
conspiracy theorists and others
immediately turned on mitch mcconnell
fomenting the republican civil war we
discussed earlier in the week
earlier this week i did a segment called
republican civil war
mega protesters chant destroy the
republican party
and that story generated quite a bit of
interest and in that segment i said
whether there is reconciliation within
the republican party as joe biden
becomes president will depend on trump
and what trump does now we um
have two sort of primary scenarios if
trump just shuts up
and disappears to play golf or do
whatever the republican party will come
back together
the wackiest elements like q anon will
evaporate and you'll get back to the
pre-trump republican party
on the other hand if donald trump and
his most ardent cultists keep going
you may have a protracted republican
civil war
and if it goes on for a few more weeks
it might actually hurt republicans in
the georgia senate runoffs which would
be great
and it's looking more and more like at
least in the next month
that second scenario is the most likely
scenario
very late last night or early this
morning i think just after midnight
eastern time
donald trump took to twitter in response
to mitch mcconnell congratulating joe
biden
and acknowledging that joe biden won and
is the president-elect trump
tweeted and quoted from an article and
said mitch
75 million votes a record for a sitting
president by a lot
too soon to give up republican party
must finally learn to fight
people are angry and indeed right on cue
the q anon conspiracy theorists q anon
being this pro-trump
conspiracy ideology listed as a domestic
terror threat
by the fbi q anon conspiracy theorists
immediately started accusing mitch
mcconnell of working for the deep state
of being a rhino a republican in name
only which is pretty funny
which uh since he's the senate majority
leader many q anon
cultist accounts on social media said
they would be leaving the republican
party because mitch mcconnell
acknowledged
an empirical reality that joe biden won
the election
and the messages from the q anon people
ranged from you're a disgrace
mitch mcconnell to today marks the birth
of the america first party
to congratulations [ __ ] mcconnell today
marked the death knell of the republican
party
because of your treasonous actions
telling party members not to back trump
so a few thoughts on this all relevant
to the next two to four years of
american politics
first trump mad at mitch mcconnell
q and on mad at mitch mcconnell trump
mad at the georgia governor brian kemp
this is a dream for democrats trying to
win these two senate seats and take
control
of the senate for the next two years
we've said the polling is close in
georgia
and it's really a toss-up i mean we've
got margins of one to two in the polls
that we're seeing for both democratic
challengers john ossoff
and rafael warnock you really can't
dream up a better scenario in a red
state where democrats are trying to win
then some republicans thinking it's
rigged against them and maybe staying
home
boycotting the election while others are
threatening to leave the party
you could not ask for a better scenario
as democratic
uh challengers trying to uh take over
seats currently held by republican
incumbents so
this little kerfuffle has the potential
to hand
senate control to democrats this also
thinking more broadly this also signals
the future about something we've talked
talked about before what happens to
trump is when trump leaves
do they simply become regular
republicans and start talking about
lowering taxes and regulations and
paying off the debt
because that's not what the q anon types
have been during the trump cult
peak years it seems to me that
for many of these q anon and trump
cultists
it's not going to be rewarding or
interesting it's going to be too milk
toast to just be
normal republicans and we might see some
of them leave politics all together
some may get involved in something more
radical and that's exactly the signal
that they're sending right now now just
a funny side note on the mitch mcconnell
congratulations thing vladimir putin and
mitch mcconnell
both congratulated joe biden this week
for winning
trump only lashed out at mitch mcconnell
i mean it's just it's poetically perfect
and it uh
it continues to be but we're getting
closer to the end
and i want to remind you january 1
21 so this is our 1-121 membership drive
we want to start the next year off
really powerfully
so on january 1st we are doing a one-day
membership special
it will be themed based on the date so
the special will be related to
1-121 okay that's all i'm saying
if you want to be if you've been
thinking i kind of like what you do
david but
you know i don't really like your voice
or i don't really like the shape of your
mouth as someone wrote to me last week
but you like the content and you've been
thinking about supporting
get on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then on january
1 you will be notified perfectly with
instructions
as to how to take advantage of this
great membership special
quick break back after this privacy.com
is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you five dollars just for using
their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman